one of the other things that's
been a big kind of deal in the running
world
in recent memory is the way that that
nike has
dealt with uh maternity leave with their
pregnant female athletes and it was a
big story that
like again back to lindsay krauss like
she's like incredible like she's
breaking all these stories she's also an
amazing runner
yeah she's getting ready for new york
right now like i just love reading
everything that she does
and she broke this story right yeah and
so this is another thing that you've
had a few things to say about so maybe
like just
explain this situation for people that
are listening who are unfamiliar
yeah um well so with
being a professional woman runner um you
kind of view your motherhood plan your
parenting plan
based on your job i think that's
probably true and well beyond sport
right
but the way contracts were set up there
was no mention
of the word pregnancy specifically but
it was well known that pregnancy was
treated as a
injury and and i don't know about this
across all brands
but i know that what first of all that's
crate right right then
like pregnancy as an injury yeah like
we're just on the wrong path
totally from the get-go and generally
athletes would have some sort of a
clause around if you don't compete
within
this many days i mean that could be as
short as eight weeks up to
six months if you don't compete within
that number of days
then you could get a contract reduction
of 50 percent or 35
or you could be dropped or if you lose
your world ranking
or your national ranking that could be
written into your contract if you lose
that or it drops below a certain amount
you would
lose significant amount of pay so as a
younger woman
looking at my contract it it didn't look
like
babies fit in there anywhere and most of
the conversations that i'd have with my
peers involved if i want to have kids
it's going to be when i retire
because you know you're going to have to
like move on
um and that's just always what i thought
i thought i i thought i'd
raise for about eight years and then
start a family and that'd be it
and and so it's just so it pushes you
into such a non-creative space and you
learn
you lose all this great talent right
when they're
entering their prime um so
what happened was alicia montano
helped bring the story forward of what
happened to her with lindsey krauss
in in that story that broke with new
york six-time olympic
yeah i mean she's she's getting
eleven-time world champion
six-time medalist she's won like six
medals but she's getting them all ten
years after the fact right from like
doping right back to the doping that's
that's kind of
those wrongs are being righted the best
they can so i think she just got
a medal at uh doa world championships
from
like 2011 or something we went to the
same high school alicia and i are really
oh you did dear friends i wasn't
bridesmaid in her wedding i mean we're
tight and so
i couldn't think of a better face for
that movement than alicia and just what
she went through but yeah
she's the one that tripped in the 800
yeah she was
at the olympic trials and had like a big
emotional display
um understandably but yeah it was
that was horrible and heartbreaking um
so that's kind of what happened she did
this beautiful
video piece plus op-ed with lindsay
krauss about
her experiences of essentially being let
go
having her contracts threatened
with asics even and then really bringing
to the forefront of people's attention
like why should this be so
especially in the wake of nike having
just produced this ad about
uh like women can do anything they can
dream of and featuring all these moms in
the ads and
all this stuff so it wouldn't be such a
big deal
of course yeah and serena this huge
story and so they're marketing women
mothers
with this lie essentially
like mother athletes doing these
incredible things with the support of
nike and these very
dramatic tear-jerking videos and then
here's the reality of what they do to
their female athletes behind closed
doors
with their contracts with their pay um
you know carrie goucher's story was
very compelling because she was
suspended
they didn't pay her for a year when she
was pregnant with colt
but they required her to do all of these
appearances i can't remember the number
if it was like 11 or 16 appearances she
was on the cover of runner's world she
actually became more famous than ever
that year she wasn't getting paid at all
but she was working for them and she was
not allowed to
seek payment from anyone else any
competitor right because exclusivity
yeah so like i don't even think that's
legal that you could
basically professionally force someone
to work for free i've heard of this
before right well
there's so many interesting facets to
this i mean when i first
kind of casually came across the story
my first instinct was
well this must be antiquated boilerplate
language
that was inserted in these contracts
forever ago and nobody bothered to
really kind of update it but i i was
resistant or reluctant to like infer
malevolence like i just thought well
this is just you know this is outdated
and they're just late to
fixing this but it sounds like there's
been women trying to challenge this all
along
and and it's not just nike i mean nike's
at the forefront of this but there are
other brands that are doing this as well
and they've been like no this is this is
the line that we're drawing in the sand
and
and i think it's it speaks to a bigger
issue
which you have like you're an
interesting figure in this
in what i want to say which is
this whole industry is built upon
this paradigm of athletic performance
like your value
is directly wed to podiums appearances
what races are you going to be on and
what podiums are you going to stand atop
we're in a very different world now and
you're like the first
generation of people and a leading voice
in this movement which is that
these things need not be so directly
coupled like you have a voice
and a point of view and a fan base and
you know legions of very loyal people
that care very much what you have to say
in my opinion that transcends whatever
podium you
like that's way more powerful for a
brand
than oh you're gonna get a silver or
bronze at some
meet in doha or whatever that the
general public
doesn't even really care about yeah but
this is the legacy of that right and i
feel like we're in this
middle ground now where these brands
haven't really cottoned on to
the fact that the world has changed
absolutely and you know i'm
i'm always uncomfortable with calling
myself a pioneer in something with this
being one exception
because you started like og blogger yeah
in 2009
when we started having these tools
available to us
um i decided because i was sort of
disillusioned at with my first six years
as a professional athlete
i thought that if i just became a
national champion
they would use me in marketing and
advertising and
we could help i could be a person that
helped bring the sport to
a greater audience and you know and i
won a national championship
and nothing happened i did great job
with interviews
it didn't matter we couldn't seem to get
anything outside of our
little circle of running media and
and i was like well when social media
and blogging
came to my attention i'm like you can
write your own story you don't have to
wait around
for non-endemic media to come knocking
on your door and decide your story's
worthwhile you make your story
worthwhile you tell your own story
and the readers will find you i mean it
was so empowering
and so i i did i started doing that in
2009
and um and so by the time 2012 came
around when my contract was going to be
up with nike
i this was my second conversation with
the ceo
at mark parker but in this one i came
into his office essentially to say hey
i want to have a baby this model that we
have that you just described so well
rich of is antiquated
why are we still basing our contracts on
this
i have been blogging i have been using
social media i have an audience i have a
story that's much richer than
it's not dependent on being on the
podium but i'm trying to resign my
contract with nike and they have
devalued me at
20 15 20 of what i was paid before but
i'm
more valuable than i've ever been and
this is crazy
like basically telling him that the
person he had in charge of
sports marketing contracts was totally
outdated and that there were
going to be missed opportunities
especially with women because when
at that moment i wanted to have a child
and was thinking
this is actually a story that applies
and is you know valuable to a lot
of women and you look at who's who's
signing up for road races
65 women right that's that's their
customer face
that's their audience like what what was
parker's response
it was like pretty lukewarm you know it
was
it was shocking to me i know and his
wife was a
world record holder in the 5k at one
point i mean what is what you know what
is the annual revenue of nike i don't
even know
it's the numbers that are it's numbers
you can't even wrap your head around
and we're talking about you know just
minute dollars to allocate towards this
thing
where if they'd gotten out in front of
it with the pregnancy stuff
or with people like yourself like
identifying like hey
lauren has a voice like there's
something really interesting going on
here
let's put a little um marketing muscle
and a few dollars behind this
and the amount of goodwill that they
could engender
with their customer base would have
the roi on that is insane so it just
seems completely myopic to me
it is it is crazy and i do think that
there was an element of mark parker not
wanting to step on the
toes of somebody that is in charge of a
department who's been there for
25 years or whatever right i'm sure that
people
don't want to get up in someone's
business unless they really really want
to go to bat for something
because i felt like the conversation
when we were eyeballed eyeball in his
office
was one where he was hearing me but i
also
didn't leave feeling like he was going
to do anything about it
um that was really discouraging and it
was a
the first time i went into mark parker's
office was
in 2006 right after i had won my u.s
championship
and i had tried to work with the global
sports marketing director trying to talk
about
how why are the why is the nike women's
catalog
completely full of models but you're
using your top male athletes
to model the clothes for your sportswear
company why are we meyer models modeling
the women's stuff and athletes modeling
you know and um he was like that's not
my department that's brand
whatever essentially like this isn't
what i do i sign
athletes and they win medals that's what
i do and so i ended up
emailing mark parker at two in the
morning by guessing his email address
based on the formula of everyone's email
address
and he emailed me back and it was jesse
who told me to do that my husband
because he was so sick of
watching me stew over it he's like just
email him i'm like all right i'll try
and he did reply and in that particular
instance when that first time i went
into his office i was so nervous
and but i was heard and changes were
made
and he sent emails and he
got a hold of his head of brand and you
know things happened
things changed and i felt it was really
it was probably the first time that i
remember
getting over the anxiety around using my
voice using it
and having something big happen um
and so yeah so it was just so different
from the second time when i came in
there you know there's everybody's got
their line and
moms didn't make it motherhood didn't
make it at that time
so i was really i was really relieved
when that story broke with alicia and
lindsey krause to see that
if i couldn't be the person that made a
difference somebody else could make a
difference yeah
the video is incredible yeah and she
does that race while she's pregnant
yeah in the video which is cool and we
should say like like
we focused a lot on nike because you
know you were with nike and
and you know nike is obviously the
biggest target but this is like an
industry yeah issue you could tell it
was industry-wide because in the wake
of the ad companies were coming out one
after the other with revised
language yeah and burton was one of the
early ones
noon um you know was all
the reason i went to wazel and they
signed me pregnant i don't know if that
has ever happened actually if a brand
signed a professional athlete
while openly pregnant with them yeah um
and you're a partner in that company
right i am yeah
that's pretty cool yeah it's very cool
um well i feel like things
are changing but they're not changing
quickly enough that's always the case
yeah right
right i guess right um we're in an era
now where
we're we're celebrating like the
strength of women athletes in a way that
we haven't before and
um and we are seeing this incredible
resurgence in
in american distance running women which
is kind of cool and incredible
but there are so many things that still
need fixing yeah there are
there are and i as a retired
professional you know athlete i'm still
really involved in the community i try
to keep my self engaged on mostly issues
of
gender equality racial equality um
ability
uh anything like that that any progress
that can be made
and i just try to make sure that i'm up
to date the best that i can
and helping kind of disseminate
information to
the audience the best i can yeah in a
very honest and authentic
way yeah you know like you don't you
don't you you're not afraid to share
your opinion you know which is what
is so awesome oh people can unfollow